there's been a lot of criticism of some
of the banks today for not stepping in
and providing more credits to Karelian
briefly why was that the case
well RBS was one of the banks involved I
mean we do have significant loans out to
Karelian and our judgment and that of
other banks was that the business plan
put forward by the company in the last
few days was not one which we thought
had a good prospect of success or of
allowing the company eventually to pay
down some of its debts left it to
highly-leveraged and obviously with our
shareholder interest in mind and of
course 70% of those shareholders are
taxpayers we have to be particularly
sure if we're going to put new money
into a company that we see a reasonable
prospect of getting it back and we did
not see that prospect so this would have
been throwing good money after that
that's the way we saw it very sad for
the company and very sad particularly
for all the employees and very worrying
for the government agencies that have
these contracts but I think that just as
the government is very hesitant about
backing it you know we cannot sensibly
put our taxpayers money through habeas
and our other shareholders money into
something where we can't see any strong
confidence of success now looking at the
brexit situation right now you've been
quite forthright in recent weeks saying
that this is going to be terrible news
for the city have you seen anything
lately that's changed your mind on that
I think it will be difficult there's
undoubtedly a lot of resistance and City
firms to moving individuals don't want
to go people like living in London so if
they can find a way of not moving people
they will but the difficulty is that the
negotiations are not proceeding very
rapidly we've done the first bit which
was supposedly the easy bit agreeing the
divorce terms but agreeing the new terms
is proving difficult and the rhetoric of
a Canada deal plus plus plus is not
particularly reassuring in the city
because there is no significant
financial services component in the
existing deal with Canada quite yeah
come and what sort of deal can the city
realistically expect do you think
it could be possible to add things to a
Canadian starting point if you like
there is in fact a financial services
chapter in the Canadian deal though it
doesn't have a great deal of content and
there was a financial services chapter
in the famous TTIP the transatlantic
trade agreement which was eventually
abortive but perhaps for other reasons
and this and so that our precedence for
the European Commission agreeing
elements of free trade in financial
services as part of a trade agreement so
I don't think we can rule out that
Canada plus plus plus plus plus might be
something which was helpful in terms of
facilitating continued cross-border
financial services but there's quite a
lot of complications there's quite a lot
of debate to be had before we get to
that point and what about the prospects
for the UK economy this year I mean
clearly we're probably gonna get at
least one interest rate rise for the
Bank of England all other things being
equal how's it looking from your point
of view I think it's light and shade the
light is that manufacturing looks pretty
good we're seeing a positive impact from
two things one that the world economy is
in actually a very good shape this is as
good as it gets pretty well everywhere
in the world except Venezuela is growing
and so exporters are getting a boost
from that and secondly of course we've
had they feed through of the impact of
sterling devaluation and that of course
is helping their profit margins or or
helping their prices so that's good they
on the less good side we could see
continued squeeze on on real earnings
because of the inflation which is the
other consequence of course of declining
sterling and so as we can see from
Christmas retail sales not so great and
I think most people would forecast that
retail sales will not be growing very
rapidly and of course also we're seeing
housing prices starting to fall in some
parts of the country so I think if
you're an export oriented manufacturer
things look pretty good just at the
moment but if you are struggling
retailer on the high street trying to
persuade the punter to get rid of that
marginal Pound I think it's it's more if
very very briefly mark carney steps down
this Bank of England governor next year
you've been linked with the job in the
past you still hovering ambitions in
that direction oh hell you know I was
deputy governor over 20 years ago things
have moved on quite a lot since then but
we'll have to see